dans la capitale trois candidates
s'affrontent pour devenir la future
maire de paris une fonction qui
n'existait pas il ya 50 ans parce qu'il
est maire de paris paris sans mère
c'était une réalité dans la capitale
depuis 1871 la ville étaient alors
représentés par le président du conseil
de paris une fonction plus honorifique
que décisionnaires dépendant du préfet
de paris et donc de l'état
une mise sous tutelle qui expliquait cet
historien en 1975 en maintes
circonstances paris en quelque sorte a
dicté sa loi à la france en uniforme en
temps de révolutions qui ont abouti à un
changement de pouvoir un changement de
gouvernement
par crainte d'éventuels soulèvements
dans la ville l'état préférait donc
garder la mainmise sur la capitale un
fonctionnement que dénonçait les membres
du conseil de paris dès le début des
années 70 il réclamait alors une réforme
profonde du statut de la capitale ce
qu'il faut avant tout c'est libérer la
ville de paris c'est-à-dire libéré paris
de la tutelle de l'état
cela veut dire en un mot que paris est
un maire après plusieurs propositions de
loi est une année de débats à
l'assemblée la loi modifiant le régime
de la ville de paris est votée le 31
décembre 1975 c'était officiel la
capitale aura de nouveau un maire il
sera en place pour six ans comme ses
collègues de province
il en aura les mêmes compétences sans
exception ni réserve il textes sauf et
c'est quand même important en matière de
pouvoirs de police qui restent de la
compétence du préfet de police
le tout après les prochaines municipales
en 77 la course au trône de la plus
belle mairie de france est lancée
aujourd'hui et la course sera effréné
elle va même entraîner une division à
droite
il y avait d'un côté le candidat des
républicains indépendants michel
d'ornano soutenu par le président valéry
giscard d'estaing et de l'autre jacques
chirac aux couleurs de son nouveau parti
le rpr
il convient maintenant d'affirmer
clairement notre résolution est de faire
en sorte que la capitale de la france ne
court pas le risque de tomber entre les
mains des socialo-communistes au
deuxième tour michel d'ornano est évincé
reste jacques chirac et le candidat
communiste henry fils bas le 25 mars
1977 après le vote des conseillers
municipaux les résultats tombaient
premier maire de paris depuis jules
ferry jacques chirac dirigera l'hôtel de
ville pendant 18 ans trois mandats qui
lui serviront de tremplin pour sa
carrière présidentielle
[Musique]